Elizabeth, j'écoute.
Attends, Jane.
Coupez !
- Comme ça...
- Ça va aller...
D'accord ?
Ta sorcière de mère.
J'écoute.
Quel con !
Ma mère vient de mourir et il
refuse que j'assiste aux funérailles.
- Traite pas mon frère de con !
- Tu le penses aussi.
Je suis sa soeur.
- C'est un mauvais réalisateur.
- Je sais.
Que veux-tu que je fasse ?
Lui botter le derrière ?
D'accord.
Maman...
Pourquoi tu es aussi triste ?
Grand-mère était une vraie
emmerdeuse.
Où as-tu appris
ce genre de langage ?
A l'école.
Ta grand-mère n'était pas
méchante. Elle était juste...
Elle était Chinoise.
Tu dois vraiment sortir ce soir ?
Je dois présenter la nouvelle
Miss Taiwan au gratin de Manhattan.
- L'avion part tôt demain.
- Chéri...
- Je ne pars pas avec toi.
- Cindy...
Ma mère est morte.
Ta fille a son récital de danse,
vendredi.
- Priorités ?
- En tant que famille...
On pourrait faire semblant
de tout à coup aimer la vipère ?
Ecoute... Nous viendrons
te rejoindre après le récital.
En fait...
ta maîtresse viendra à Seattle ?
Jane, c'est ça ?
Comment grand-mère est morte ?
Emily...
Je suis contente
que vous soyez tous là.
Votre mère n'a eu qu'un seul
dernier voeu.
Des funérailles chinoises
traditionnelles...
- D'une durée de 7 jours.
- 7 jours ?
- Mon père n'a pas eu droit à ça.
- Il ne l'a jamais demandé.
7 jours ?
Les injections de botox de tes
patients ne peuvent pas attendre ?
Merci, Viola.
On fera tout pour que ma mère
aie des funérailles traditionnelles.
Comment ? On est Américains.
On ne parle même pas le chinois.
Elizabeth, tu dois t'y connaître.
Tu vis à Hong Kong.
Non, je ne sais pas du tout
comment ça se passe.
Notre mère n'a pas voulu
nous élever comme des Chinois.
Je sais un tas de choses
sur les funérailles chinoises.
J'étais Chinoise
dans une vie antérieure.
- Arrête tes bêtises !
- Alex...
Je fais partie de cette famille
depuis que tu es tout petit.
Vous avez manqué
son 70e anniversaire.
J'avais l'intention de venir.
Je voulais juste
ne pas être seule.
Vous n'avez pas téléphoné.
Aucun d'entre vous.
- J'ai posté une carte.
- Elle l'a reçue 2 jours après.
Viola, merci d'avoir pris soin
d'elle et de nous.
Mais tu n'as pas à nous dire
tout ça.
- Votre mère avait le cancer.
- Quoi ?
- Elle ne nous a jamais rien dit.
- Vous ne lui avez jamais demandé.
Elle est morte toute seule.
Et vous dans tout ça ?
Vous vous parlez ? A quand
remonte votre dernière réunion ?
Arrête !
Tu en as assez dit.
Elizabeth...
Pourquoi Michael n'est pas là ?
On s'est séparés. Ça fait un an.
Juste après la mort de Sammy.
- Désolée.
- Ecoute,
notre mère a passé sa vie à nous
braquer les uns contre les autres.
Ses dernières paroles
étaient empreintes d'amour.
Elle espérait avoir
votre pardon.
Donc, la première chose à faire,
c'est de trouver des moines...
Pour les chants.
Tu ne voudrais pas
organiser ça ?
D'accord. Des moines chantants.
Combien et où ça se trouve ?
Au temple. Je sais où c'est.
Les enfants du défunt doivent
s'agenouiller devant l'autel,
3 fois par jour,
10 minutes chacun
et avant d'aller se coucher.
Quelqu'un a des nouvelles
de Mei Mei ?
Tu crois qu'elle viendra ?
Je n'arrive pas à croire
qu'elle est partie.
La dernière fois qu'on s'est
parlées, je lui ai raccroché au nez.
Moi aussi.
Elle n'a jamais été fière
de moi.
De nous non plus.
J'ai rêvé que ça arriverait.
C'était un cauchemar...
Effrayant.
Elle s'était éteinte et...
Quoi ?
On s'en fichait, Alex.
C'est ce qui était si effrayant.
Quel beau portrait de famille !
Mei Mei. Dede.
- Salut !
- Où est le corps ?
A la morgue.
- C'est quoi tout ça ?
- Un autel !
Trop cool !
Même en Chine,
on ne fait plus ça.
- Un autel ?
- Ouais.
Pour les morts. Les fantômes.
Tu veux goûter ?
Maman !
- Maman !
- Mei Mei.
Tu es partie trop tôt !
Tu joues vraiment trop mal.
Il n'y a pas de caméras ici.
Debout.
Votre mère est morte.
Vous ne pouvez pas essayer
d'être plus gentils entre vous.
Tu n'es pas de la famille.
Tu n'es pas la bienvenue.
Alex... connard !
Tu n'as rien mangé.
Je fais attention à ma ligne.
T'as déjà vu une grosse ninja ?
Mange.
Je suis abonnée à ton magazine.
Je lis ton éditorial
tous les mois.
J'ai vu ton dernier film.
Il était bien.
Pas vraiment.
Ecoute...
Liz...
Je sais que tu es fâchée
contre moi.
Désolée de ne pas être
venue aux funérailles de Sammy.
Crois-moi.
C'est juste que...
J'étais...
- Sur un tournage. C'est rien.
- Ce n'est pas rien.
Dis ce que tu ressens.
D'accord. Ce n'était pas rien.
C'est pour ça que tu t'es
séparée de Michael ?
Tu le vois encore
de temps en temps ?
Il est venu me voir
de Los Angeles il y a un mois.
- Il a passé le week-end avec moi.
- Tu l'aimes toujours ?
- Tu crois encore à l'amour ?
- Liz... Absolument !
Tu es vraiment aussi naïve ?
- Tu parles comme maman.
- Pas du tout.
Dede et moi voulons
avoir un bébé.
- Tu vas te fâcher ?
- Un bébé ? Comment ?
Du sperme.
On a juste besoin de sperme.
Du sperme, évidemment.
Tu vas te fâcher ?
Non. Arrête de me demander ça.
Excusez-moi.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle a ?
- Elle a perdu son fils.
- Je sais.
Je veux que tu déboutonnes
ta chemise.
Je veux que tu sentes
ma langue, mes lèvres.
Mes mains
le long de tes cuisses.
Non... arrête ça.
Dix minutes.
Viola...
J'aimerais passer à la morgue...
Je veux la voir.
Tu la verras,
le jour des funérailles.
Quand elle sera apprêtée.
Tu sais à quel point
elle était coquette.
Qu'en penses-tu ?
Lui. Du sperme de moine.
Dede, t'exagères.
Excusez-moi, mais on essaie
de faire un bébé.
- C'est dégoûtant.
- Comment ?
Tu as dit quoi ?
Toi, la catin !
- Tu ferais mieux de la fermer.
- Arrêtez !
On est seulement ensemble
pour 7 jours.
On a plein de choses à faire.
Contacter les amis et les proches.
Il y a le cimetière
et la pierre tombale.
Les choses que votre mère
emmènera dans l'au-delà,
le banquet.
L'éloge funèbre,
que les chinois appellent
le résumé.
Lors du 5è jour, les gens
viendront présenter leurs respects.
C'est presque humiliant, que
tu saches tout ça et pas nous.
Je sais.
Alex, quand Cindy viendra ?
Où est Miss bloc-de-glace ?
Ne me dis pas que Miss Taiwan
1993 ne viendra pas.
Elle doit arriver ce week-end.
Emily avait un récital.
Elle ne voulait pas venir plus tôt
parce qu'elle ne vous supporte pas.
Je la comprends.
Charmant.
Vous ressentez le Feng Shui ?
Regardez la lumière et la vue.
C'est joli.
Comment notre mère a trouvé ça ?
Notre mère ?
C'est moi, l'agent immobilier.
- Tu vends des maisons aux morts ?
- Tais-toi !
Ça fait partie de mon métier.
J'ai réussi à en tirer un bon
prix de ces emplacements.
Des caveaux ?
Tu en as acheté plusieurs ?
Dites-leur.
Le fils et son épouse doivent
être enterrés
- à côté de la mère et du père.
- Notre père a été incinéré.
Ses cendres se sont retrouvées
dans l'aspirateur.
C'est de ma faute.
J'étais jeune.
C'est quoi l'histoire du fils
et de son épouse ?
Mme Xiao a acheté 3 caveaux :
un pour elle, un pour vous
et un pour votre femme.
C'est la tradition.
- Achetez-en 2. Le 3è est gratuit.
- Tu m'étonnes.
Tais-toi !
Nous refusons
d'être enterrés ici.
Si t'aimes tellement cet endroit,
tu n'as qu'à venir t'enterrer ici.
Je connaissais votre père.
Un monsieur puissant.
Vous êtes pareil,
mais vous ne le réalisez pas.
Vous avez des responsabilités
à assumer.
Les funérailles doivent inspirer
le respect.
Vous faites le deuil
de votre mère.
C'est pour ça que vous avez
l'esprit embrouillé.
Pas vrai ?
- Alex.
- Non.
Comment tu as fait pour
te consacrer à notre famille ?
J'ai été mariée très jeune
contre ma volonté.
Je me suis retrouvée veuve
très jeune aussi...
contre ma volonté.
Mais... me voilà.
Et fonder ta propre famille ?
Il existe toutes sortes de familles,
tu devrais le savoir.
Ils sont ma famille et je suis
prête à tout pour les aider.
Tout.
Tu sais, j'aurais aimé...
avoir une mère comme toi.
Mei Mei parle souvent de toi.
- Tu as vu ?
- Quoi ?
Les rideaux.
La chambre de Madame Xiao.
Ils ont... ils ont bougé.
Non. C'est le vent.
- Tu crois aux fantômes ?
- Non...
- Peut-être. Et toi ?
- Tout à fait.
Il faut que je fume un joint.
Dix minutes.
Alors... On peut manger ?
Oui. Ton plat préféré. Pizza !
- Salut !
- Comment tu t'appelles ?
- Bruce. Lee.
- Bruce Lee ?
- Mes parents l'adoraient.
- On peut parler ?
- Viens.
Michael ?
- Vous êtes lesbiennes ?
- Exactement !
Toi, tu es un moine.
Un moine,
qui s'autorise le sexe.
Bruce. Il n'est pas question
d'avoir du sexe.
- Pas de sexe ?
- Non.
Comment alors ?
D'accord...
Evidemment.
Faut que je réfléchisse.
- Mei ?
- Oui. Vous êtes ?
Chow Lin.
Vous savez quelle heure il est ?
A Beijing, on est déjà debout.
Votre mère était une bonne amie.
Je vous laisse prendre
mes bagages.
Bananes.
Potassium.
C'est bon pour la digestion.
Votre mère m'a souvent
montré des photos de vous.
Et des cassettes
de vos horribles films.
Je sais tout... sur vous.
Chow Lin !
Quel bonheur
de vous avoir parmi nous.
C'est moi, qui vous a contacté.
Viola.
Viola...
La dame juive qui sait préparer
les meilleures ravioles au monde.
Vous voulez manger
quelque chose ?
Des plats américains.
J'ai envie de manger
comme un porc !
- Suivez-moi.
- Comme un porc !
Impressionnant.
Y'a pas de bon burger à Beijing.
Aucune bonne crêpe.
Pas de lard.
Je rêve d'aller manger...
- au Burger King.
- Burger King ?
Mei Mei rêve souvent
de manger au Burger King.
Pour vous. Buvez ça.
Buvez.
Enchanté de vous connaître.
C'est un honneur.
Et maintenant,
je dois lâcher un gros pet !
Je vais vous montrer
les toilettes.
Qui c'est ?
- Un célèbre pianiste chinois.
- Sans blague ?
- Maman l'a rencontré à Rome.
- Rome ?
- Elle est allée à Rome ?
- Oui, avant ta naissance.
- C'était les vacances scolaires.
- Tu connais ce monsieur ?
- Je n'étais qu'une enfant.
- Tu es restée une enfant.
J'aime bien Chow Lin.
Une personne
avec un appétit aussi vorace,
- est un homme passionné.
- J'y vais !
- C'est le 2è jour, donc...
- C'est pas le 3è ?
- Officiellement, c'est le 2è.
- Mais en réalité, c'est le 3è.
C'est le 2è.
Regardez. C'est Michael.
- Bonjour Michael.
- Salut !
Merci d'être venu.
Ma mère t'a toujours aimé.
- Je ne sais pas pourquoi.
- Moi non plus.
Tu sais...
De tous ses enfants,
tu es la seule qui l'appelle maman.
Ça te pose problème ?
Liz. C'est ta mère.
Tu sais que je ne suis pas
venu pour elle.
Je suis venu pour toi...
Pour nous.
Mère nous a quittés.
Sammy nous a quittés.
Il ne reviendra plus.
Ne te blâme pas.
Tu n'y es pour rien.
Regarde-moi.
Je t'aime.
C'est long !
T'as bientôt fini ?
Ça fait un bout de temps...
Coucou !
Désolé...
Ce n'est pas comme si
je pouvais le faire sur commande.
- Non ?
- Non,
j'ai besoin d'inspiration, ou...
d'un coup de main.
Alors...
utilise ton imagination.
Je te l'ai dit.
Pas de sexe.
Fais travailler...
ton imagination.
Ton imagination.
Désolé... j'ai essayé.
Ça ne fait rien. Merci.
J'ai beaucoup réfléchi hier soir.
J'ai envie de vous être utile.
Après tout, on n'est pas là pour
célébrer la mort.
C'est la vie, qu'on célèbre.
Peut-être qu'un jour, on mangera
des dim sum ensemble.
Mei Mei, tu connais
la signification du mot "dim sum" ?
Non.
Ça signifie "toucher le coeur".
T'es trop mignon.
Liz, maman adorait la Mercedes
GE-500.
Ah bon ? Elle coûte plus
de cent mille dollars.
On ne t'a pas demandé
de lui acheter.
Je n'ai rien dit alors.
Drôle de coutume.
On achète toutes ces choses
pour les brûler ?
J'aime bien l'idée, que maman
puisse ramener tout ça avec elle.
T'as qu'à lui acheter
une Mercedes.
Elle aimait beaucoup sa Jaguar.
Pourquoi ne pas s'en servir ?
Cette épave ?
On va dire,
qu'on est irrespectueux.
Alors ? La Jag décapotable
- ou la Mercedes ?
- On prend les deux.
C'est pour votre mère ?
Il lui faut le meilleur.
Il faut tout lui donner.
Offrez-lui un million de dollars.
- On paye les frais d'expédition.
- Les frais d'expédition ?
- Tout vient de Tai Pei.
- On en a besoin très vite.
Et alors ?
Vous ne connaissez pas Fedex ?
- On va prendre la Mercedes.
- Et le million de dollars.
Et il nous faut une maison.
Une photo de sa maison
ne suffira pas ?
Ça porte malheur. Personne
ne voudra acheter sa maison.
- On ne la vend pas.
- Non ?
- Père voulait qu'on la garde.
- Pourquoi ?
On n'y a même pas grandi.
Ça, c'était du bel ouvrage.
Vivre dans une maison
préfabriquée ?
Pas moi. Père la lui a offerte
pour se racheter.
- Se racheter ?
- Quoi d'autre ?
Un valet ? Une bonne ?
Je refuse de brûler des humains,
même faits en carton.
Pas de valet, ni de bonne.
J'ai des phénix et des dragons.
Ils sont en promo.
Vous payez ce que vous cassez !
C'est déjà juste
pour une taille enfant,
alors pour une femme normale...
Elles devaient se bander
les pieds très serrés
pour qu'ils cessent de grandir.
Je préfère encore
les talons-aiguilles.
Une lettre jamais postée.
Ecrite par notre mère
à sa propre mère.
Elle avait une mère ?
- Mon Dieu.
- Quoi ?
- Son vrai nom.
- Quoi ? Linda ?
- Son nom chinois.
- C'était pas Linda ?
Lingyun !
- C'est joli.
- Ça veut dire quoi ?
Le nuage le plus haut dans le ciel.
C'est signe de force.
- Lis la lettre.
- D'accord.
Mon Dieu. Regardez.
C'est moi, qui le lui avais fait
pour la fête des mères.
J'étais en CP.
C'est fou, qu'elle l'ait gardée.
- Regardez !
- Nounours blanc.
- Bonjour. Je suis nounours blanc.
- Nounours blanc ?
Alex a dormi avec
jusqu'au lycée.
Tais-toi.
- Je n'étais pas au courant.
- Quoi ?
Personne ne doit
être au courant.
De quoi ?
Durant la famine, maman avait
16 ans et elle était amoureuse.
Sa mère a voulu qu'elle épouse
un homme dans le cadre...
d'un mariage arrangé.
Elle s'est donc enfuie
à Hong Kong.
Son amoureux devait
la rejoindre, mais...
il n'est jamais arrivé.
Il a été tué en traversant
une rivière.
Quelle triste histoire.
Et ensuite ?
A Hong Kong, elle a rencontré
un autre homme...
beaucoup plus vieux qu'elle.
Elle n'était pas sûre de l'aimer,
mais il était gentil.
Papa ?
Elle l'a finalement aimé
et ils sont venus ici à Seattle...
Et vécurent heureux
jusqu'à la fin des temps.
Pas tout à fait.
Je me souviens
de leurs disputes...
après ta naissance.
- Papa n'était pas fidèle.
- C'est vrai ?
Je l'ai vu...
avec d'autres femmes.
Y en a eu plusieurs ?
Il disait aimer maman.
Evidemment.
Tu dis la même chose, quand tu
en as assez d'une de tes maîtresses ?
- Mei Mei.
- Allons...
Un prestigieux médecin comme
Alex, veut nous faire croire
qu'il n'a jamais eu
de maîtresse ?
Je ne cherche à rien
vous faire croire.
Pourquoi rompre
avec la tradition familiale
des secrets et des mensonges ?
Arrêtez votre cirque !
On doit rédiger une éloge funèbre
pour une mère,
dont on ne sait pas grand chose.
Qu'est-ce qu'on va dire ?
Tiens.
- J'ai gagné.
- Je t'ai laissé gagner.
Parce que t'es vieux.
C'est un bon petit gars.
Où est son père ?
- Demandez à ma mère.
- Hein ?
Elle m'a obligée de quitter le seul
homme que j'aie jamais aimé.
Pourquoi ?
Il n'était pas chinois.
On allait se marier...
Mais quand ma mère s'est mis
quelque chose en tête...
Je sais.
Qu'êtes-vous venu faire ici ?
Franchement.
Viola m'a dit que votre mère
tenait à ce que je sois présent.
Alors, me voilà.
Vous l'aimiez ?
Salut.
Je ne peux pas croire
que tu cours encore.
que toi non.
On doit choisir une pierre
tombale aujourd'hui.
Tu veux que je vienne ?
Non.
Tu n'es pas obligé.
Ecoute...
Tu m'as demandé de venir.
Je suis venu.
Ne me repousse pas.
Liz...
C'est normal que Sam te manque.
Il me manque tous les jours.
On doit continuer à vivre.
Ecoute,
laisse-moi revenir avec toi.
S'il te plaît...
Voyons...
S'il s'agissait de ma mère,
rien ne serait trop cher,
ou trop exagéré.
Regardez ces jolis autels
de marbre.
Vous pourriez ériger
la statue de votre mère dessus.
Du solide !
Je connais un sculpteur.
Je peux vous avoir un prix d'ami.
Si c'était ma mère...
Je ferais faire son portrait.
Pas comme elle était...
Comme elle était dans mes rêves.
Vous pourriez l'exposer
sur ce reposoir.
Je connais un peintre,
je peux vous avoir un prix d'ami.
J'aime celui-là.
- Si c'était ma mère...
- Ce n'est pas votre mère !
C'est ma mère.
C'est notre mère. C'est clair ?
- Alex, ça va aller ?
- Ça va.
J'aime cette pierre,
toute simple et blanche.
D'accord ?
- On peut avoir un prix d'ami ?
- Bien sûr.
Mei Mei, raccompagne-le.
Alex !
Qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
Désolé.
J'en voulais à papa
d'avoir trompé notre mère.
Elle en a souffert.
Je m'étais juré de ne jamais
devenir comme lui.
Je fais comme lui.
Maman me regarde
et elle sait que je mens.
Que je trompe et que ma femme
me déteste.
- Il y a des raisons qui...
- Ça n'a rien de rationnel.
Que dois-je faire ?
Ben...
Tu aimes Cindy ?
Tu l'aimes vraiment ?
Je l'aimais.
Tu l'aimes toujours ?
Pourquoi veux-tu ça ?
On doit être chez Mme Sun
dans vingt minutes...
On fait mieux d'y aller.
Je voudrais la chanter
aux funérailles.
- Elle adorait cette chanson.
- Elle est très jolie.
Je ne savais pas que ma mère
aimait cette chanson.
Mme Sun, vous étiez la couturière
préférée de ma mère...
- J'étais sa seule couturière.
- Bien sûr.
Il faut lui faire
une dernière robe.
En Chine, ce sont les filles
qui font la dernière robe.
- On n'est pas en Chine.
- Ma soeur veut dire...
- Vous êtes l'actrice.
- Vous voulez dire, la lesbienne ?
Elle a couché avec un noir.
Liz est celle qui vient
de perdre son fils
et Alex a une maîtresse.
On sait ce que mère pensait de nous,
alors, arrêtons de tourner
autour du pot !
Nous exauçons son dernier voeu.
Des funérailles chinoises
avec une robe traditionnelle.
D'accord ou pas ?
Vous me plaisez. Votre mère
était fière de vous.
De vous tous.
Elle n'arrêtait pas de dire :
"Mon fils, le médecin".
"Ma fille, la journaliste".
"Ma fille, dans l'immobilier".
"Ma fille, la star".
Je lui ferai une robe.
Elle sera magnifique.
A l'image de votre mère.
Je ne sais plus. Je croyais savoir
quoi dire dans mon discours...
Comment disait-elle être
si fière aux gens,
alors qu'avec nous,
elle était...
Si emmerdeuse ?
Egoïste ? Cruelle ? Arrogante ?
Manipulatrice ?
Dictatoriale ?
Sauver les apparences.
Croyez-vous au destin ?
Oui. Et vous ?
Oui.
Je pense qu'on est tous reliés,
sans même que l'on s'en rende
compte.
On est comme les ingrédients
d'un merveilleux plat.
Votre herbe fait effet.
Je pense que je suis amoureuse.
Liz... le repas est servi.
J'arrive.
Michael.
Je ne t'en veux pas.
Je m'excuse de n'avoir
jamais su m'exprimer.
Laisse-moi un peu plus de temps.
Je n'ai pas l'intention
de m'en aller.
Mei Mei.
Salut !
Je voulais juste te dire...
je suis prêt à réessayer.
Si tu es toujours partante.
Oui. D'accord.
Ce serait parfait. Merci.
Très bien.
- Alors à demain ?
- A demain.
- Au revoir.
- Bonne nuit.
Bonne nuit, Bruce.
Bonne nuit.
- L'eau est chaude ?
- Elle est parfaite.
Mon Dieu ! Génial.
On vient de corrompre un moine.
Votre mère m'a chargée
de vous lire le testament.
Pourquoi ?
Tu n'es pas de la famille.
- Viola fait partie de la famille.
- C'est moi, le fils.
- C'est tellement sexiste.
- Pardon, Viola. Vas-y, continue.
Je me disais que ce serait
le moment
de prendre connaissance
du testament.
Etant donné que vous vous
débrouillez tous très bien.
Oui.
On a droit à quoi ?
- Rien.
- Rien ?
La maison vous revient de droit.
C'était le voeu de votre père.
Et son assurance-vie,
son or et ses bijoux ?
Elle se disait qu'avec l'héritage
de votre père,
vous ne seriez pas à plaindre.
Je n'arrive pas à y croire.
Elle a tout légué
au centre communautaire
de la côte pacifique.
- Le quoi ?
- Le centre communautaire.
- Elle croyait à la bonne cause.
- Sérieux ?
Ne viens pas me dire
en quoi croyait ma mère.
Je trouve que c'est
une bonne idée.
Ça ne me surprend pas.
Elle a toujours été super radine
avec nous.
Avec toi aussi, Viola.
- Comment tu as pu la supporter ?
- Parce que je l'aimais.
Parce que je vous aimais tous.
Et je vous aime encore.
Je dois aller à l'aéroport.
Je vais chercher Emily et Cindy.
- Tu veux que je vienne ?
- Ça va aller.
Vous avez pris cette photo.
Vous vous souvenez ?
A côté du Vatican.
Vous n'êtes pas venu ternir
la réputation de ma mère ?
Non. Jamais.
Je ne l'ai jamais dit à personne,
après toutes ces années.
C'est pour ça qu'elle me critiquait
moins que les autres.
- Elle avait peur de moi.
- Non.
Elle était reconnaissante.
Vous avez gardé le secret.
Cindy.
Je suis désolé.
Je veux qu'on reprenne
tout à zéro.
On est là !
Cindy... Emily.
Bienvenue.
Bonjour, Victoria.
Je vois que tu n'as pas changé.
- Connasse !
- Qu'est-ce qu'elle a dit ?
"Connasse" !
Je suis enceinte.
Liz !
Tiens, maman.
Prends bien soin de Sammy
pour nous.
Vas-y.
Maman...
Je te présente Dede.
Je suis sûre, que tu l'aimeras.
Dede.
Voilà.
- Y'en a beaucoup.
- Je m'étais réservé...
Merci.
J'ai eu une révélation.
Je ne suis pas moine.
Mais si.
Pas au fond de moi.
Je ne le suis plus...
C'est ça ma révélation.
- Je vais en enfer pour ça ?
- Non.
Dede. Je tiens à te remercier.
Et Mei Mei aussi.
Je suis devenu moine
pour des mauvaises raisons.
Pour plaire à mes parents...
à tout le monde sauf à moi
et ce n'est pas une vie.
L'honnêteté, que toi
et Mei Mei avez
et la manière dont vous vivez
ouvertement en toute simplicité,
je trouve ça très inspirant.
Je veux me marier.
Et avoir beaucoup d'enfants.
Et j'espère qu'un d'entre eux,
sera le tien et celui de Mei Mei.
Je pars demain.
J'aimerais que tu dises
"au revoir" de ma part à Mei Mei.
- Tu peux y aller toi-même.
- Non.
C'est mieux de cette façon.
Je suis enceinte.
Quand tu es venu
à Hong Kong le mois dernier.
Qu'en penses-tu ?
Merci mon Dieu.
Mei Mei. Ça fait des heures
que je te cherche.
Regarde.
Le moine a livré.
Ça va ?
- J'ai trouvé ça sur mon oreiller.
- C'est de qui ?
Ma mère !
Qu'est-ce qu'elle a écrit ?
Ça va ?
Non, pas du tout.
- Qu'y a-t-il ?
- Mei Mei !
Qu'est-ce que ce qui se passe ?
Il est écrit...
qu'il est temps
de dire la vérité.
La vérité ?
Je suis... le vrai père
de Mei Mei.
J'hallucine !
Mei Mei.
Votre mère et moi...
étions très amoureux.
On a voulu garder le secret
pour toi.
Taisez-vous !
Vous n'avez rien à me dire !
Je ne veux rien entendre !
Ma vie est un mensonge !
Mei Mei...
Pourquoi tu ne me l'a pas dit ?
Pourquoi tu ne m'as rien dit ?
Pourquoi ?
Calme-toi.
Ça va aller.
Pourquoi tu ne me l'a pas dit ?
Maman m'avait fait promettre
de ne rien dire.
Tout le monde était au courant ?
Même notre père ?
Je crois qu'il s'en est douté.
Tout le monde avait des doutes.
Mais personne n'était sûr.
Les choses ne sont jamais
toutes blanches ou noires.
Non. Tu as raison.
Sauver les apparences...
Sauver les apparences.
Je déteste cette expression.
Oui.
Moi aussi.
C'est très chinois.
On est Chinois.
Oui.
C'est vrai.
- Bonjour.
J'allais justement faire du café,
tu en veux ?
- Jamais de café, merci.
- D'accord. Alors...
Aujourd'hui, c'est le 5è jour ?
Les invités doivent venir
rendre leurs hommages ?
Je parie que tu as tout organisé.
L'organisation,
c'est une preuve de respect.
Tu sais... Je suis bonne
cuisinière, tu veux de l'aide ?
Victoria connaît un bon restaurant
de fruits de mer.
- Ils serviront un buffet.
- Un buffet ?
C'est pas très chic...
Mais ça ressemble bien
à Victoria.
Tu sais, tu n'es plus une Miss.
- Pardon ?
- Tu m'as bien entendue.
Tu devrais te tenir à ta place.
Ma place est auprès
de cette famille.
Où est la tienne ?
Ta belle-mère désirait
une chose par-dessus tout,
c'est que cette famille puisse
se réunir une bonne fois pour toutes.
Ce serait merveilleux
si ça pouvait marcher, non ?
Il est difficile de savoir
pardonner.
Je sais.
Pardonner est l'une des choses
les plus dures dans une vie.
J'espère que tu arriveras
un jour, sinon
tu deviendras très malheureuse.
Alors ?
Quoi ?
On tente notre chance ?
On fait table rase.
Mei Mei...
Te rencontrer a complètement
changé ma vie.
Et complètement changé
la mienne.
J'ai décidé de ne plus jouer
dans des mauvais films d'action.
Que vas-tu faire alors ?
Aucune idée.
Ça ne te fait pas peur ?
Non...
Comment je t'appelle ?
Je m'appelle Chow Lin.
Ils n'ont engagé qu'un seul moine.
Ça fait pingre.
Je peux avoir votre autographe ?
Tu aimes les films de kung-fu ?
Tous les vendredis,
votre mère venait m'acheter
des fleurs coupées.
Elle était avare, mais loyale.
Ces fleurs...
ne viennent pas de ma boutique.
Désolée. Victoria les a achetées
chez le fleuriste du quartier.
- Je vois...
- Mangez quelque chose.
Asseyez-vous.
Votre mère,
a payé les frais médicaux
de mon mari pendant deux ans.
Comment l'avez-vous connue ?
Elle faisait du bénévolat
au centre communautaire.
Vous ne le saviez pas ?
Notre mère était pleine
de surprises.
Plus de cent personnes
sont passées ce matin.
Mamie a dû être quelqu'un
de sympa.
T'as raison.
Ils diront quoi à notre sujet,
quand on aura quitté ce monde ?
- Ils diront qu'on a essayé.
- On a essayé.
- Des gens disent des conneries.
- Des conneries ?
Des trucs sur toi, grand-mère
et Mei Mei.
- Les enfants entendent tout.
- Evidemment.
Tu fais partie de ma famille ?
- Oui. Ça te pose problème ?
- Non, c'est chouette !
Tu veux connaître
un truc chouette ?
- Le Tai Chi.
- Comme dans les films ?
- Alexandre.
- Merci, Mme Sun.
- Victoria.
- Merci.
Mei Mei... Elizabeth.
La tradition,
c'est très important.
C'est vrai.
Merci.
Au revoir.
Merci d'être venues.
Et en parlant de tradition,
je me rappelle d'un défi lancé
il y a très longtemps,
entre Alex et moi,
Victoria et Élizabeth.
- Vous êtes prêtes ?
- Non.
- Elizabeth ne peut pas jouer.
- Pourquoi ?
- Demande-lui.
- Pourquoi pas ?
Tu es...
Mon Dieu.
Dieu m'a certainement aidé.
Mais c'est surtout Michael.
Le dernier moine est rentré.
Il faut se recueillir et prier.
Selon les anciens rituels,
à la fin d'un deuil,
l'âme du défunt revient,
avant de repartir.
Agenouillez-vous devant l'autel.
Fermez vos yeux.
Essayez de la voir
au fond de vous.
Vous la voyez ?
Je suis avec vous,
mes chers enfants.
Même morte,
elle me fout la trouille.
Suis-je vraiment morte ?
Alexandre,
tu as l'air si sérieux.
Je dois m'asseoir.
Assieds-toi.
Vous devez tous être en colère.
Ecoutez...
je vais bientôt mourir.
Cancer du foie.
Les médecins me donnent
encore six mois.
Vous croyiez, que j'avais envie
de mourir comme Mme Chu ?
Jamais une gentille parole
de la part de ses enfants,
jusqu'à ce qu'elle s'en aille.
Vous croyiez que j'avais envie
de mourir comme votre père ?
Pleine de regrets ?
Non.
Je voulais que ma famille
puisse se réunir.
Je sais.
Je n'ai pas toujours été
une mère exemplaire.
J'espère qu'un jour,
j'arriverai à mieux faire.
Je tiens à vous dire,
ce que je ressens.
Et je veux savoir,
ce que vous ressentez vraiment.
Ce que tu viens de faire,
nous prouve à quel point
tu peux être manipulatrice,
égoïste, arrogante et envahissante.
- C'est un bon début.
- Je n'ai pas fini.
Je ne crois pas un seul instant,
que tu veuilles savoir
- ce que nous ressentons.
- On essayait juste...
Arrête.
N'essaie pas de rationnaliser.
Mourir, n'est jamais rationnel.
Comme ton monstrueux ego.
J'ai fait ça pour toi, Alex.
Maman,
tu es tellement présomptueuse,
que tu as fini par le croire.
Quelqu'un d'autre ?
Félicitations. Très dramatique.
Très Chinois.
- Tu vois, elle, elle comprend.
- Pas du tout.
Tu nous as fait beaucoup
souffrir. Toi aussi, Viola.
Tu es fâchée ?
Je n'ai jamais été
aussi furieuse.
Ce ne sont pas les réactions
auxquelles je m'attendais.
Tu t'attendais à quoi ?
Qu'on remercierait le ciel
que tu sois encore vivante ?
Oui.
Oublie ça.
Peut-être que j'aurais dû
rester morte.
Ça aurait été plus sage.
Vous savez à quel point
j'aime votre fille ?
Oui, j'avais deviné.
Ça me fait très plaisir.
Bienvenue dans notre folle
famille.
Merci.
J'aimerais savoir,
comment vous avez fait !
Oui.
La maison est grande.
Il y a une pièce secrète
adjacente à ma chambre.
Avec une salle de bain.
Viola m'a tenue informée
de toutes les allées et venues.
J'ai moi-même entendu
des choses ici et là.
- Bien joué.
- Oui.
Je sais.
Et voici ma plus grande
surprise.
Je devrais être en colère
contre toi.
Un peu.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec Alexandre ?
Je vais aller lui parler.
Excusez-moi. J'espère que
vous ne m'en voulez pas.
C'est mon réalisateur.
Je dois répondre.
- C'est bien Dede Chan ?
- Oui, c'est moi.
Vous êtes ?
Je suis l'assistant réalisateur
de votre frère.
Il vient d'avoir une crise
cardiaque, ici à Los Angeles.
Ils l'ont amené à l'hôpital
Memorial Peterson.
Pour l'instant,
son état est stable.
Alexandre...
Laisse-moi tranquille !
Tu n'es pas comme ton père.
Tu as sûrement commis
des erreurs, tout comme moi.
Mais mes enfants,
ne seront jamais des erreurs.
Ils sont la meilleure chose
qui ne me soit jamais arrivée.
Ça fait longtemps
que tu es en colère.
Et ces derniers jours,
j'ai senti que cette colère
s'estompait.
Tu ne voudrais pas toujours
vivre de cette façon ?
Mon fils adoré.
J'ai fait ça,
en espérant que l'on puisse
tous retrouver le bonheur.
S'il est déplacé de la part
d'une mère de vouloir aimer
ses enfants une dernière fois,
alors oui, ce que j'ai fait
était déplacé.
Je t'aime aussi.
T'es sûre que tu ne veux pas
que je t'accompagne ?
Mes bagages sont faits,
je suis prête.
Non, ça ira.
- Je suis sérieuse, Dede.
- Je veux que tu restes.
Combien de fois je dois
te le répéter ?
Ton frère vient d'avoir
une crise cardiaque.
Ce n'est pas rien.
Laisse-moi être là pour toi.
Je comprends,
mais ta famille a besoin de toi.
Reste ici.
- Je t'aime, Dede Chan.
- Moi aussi, je t'aime.
Vas-y.
Sois forte.
Je ne cherche pas d'excuses
pour votre mère et Viola.
Mais regardez-nous. On est là.
On se parle.
Et je crois même
avoir entendu...
quelques rires.
On devrait peut-être
s'estimer heureux,
que tout ça soit arrivé
avant qu'on ne meure.
Avant qu'elle meure.
Je trouve, que Dede a bien fait
d'aller le rejoindre.
Tu ferais la même chose
pour ton frère, c'est sûr.
Et il ferait la même chose
pour toi.
Sans hésiter.
Il mange toujours autant ?
Toujours.
Maman,
je ne veux pas
que tu nous quittes.
Moi non-plus.
Merci, Victoria.
Mei Mei...
Désolée pour le frère de Dede.
Merci.
J'ai failli oublier.
Il faut annuler le banquet.
Non, il faut le faire.
Il faut bien célébrer la vie.
Ta vie.
Michael, je t'ai toujours aimé.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi !
Sûrement pour rendre Alex
jaloux.
Je crois que personne ne te
connaissait avant cette semaine.
Tu es plus intelligente
que tu parais.
Merci !
Quant à toi...
Bravo !
Ce soir je tiens à m'adresser
à Mme Xiao.
Votre tenue...
vaut beaucoup plus, que ce
que j'ai demandé à vos enfants.
Et ce que vous venez de faire
pour eux... C'est merveilleux.
Vous croyez que mes enfants
se feraient avoir ?
Vos enfants sont trop malins
pour ça.
Charmant !
Merci de votre présence.
A ceux qui ont donné
de l'argent à la maison,
Victoria s'assurera
de tous vous rembourser.
Mais je tiens à garder
ma jolie tenue.
C'est une superbe soirée
d'adieu.
Vous avez fait de moi une vieille
dame parfaitement comblée.
Affronter la mort,
change tout.
Donc, la "femme de fer"
n'est plus.
La vie est si fragile.
Nous devons la chérir
tous les jours,
ainsi que tous ceux
qui nous tiennent à coeur.
Dans quelques jours,
je vais partir en Chine
avec Monsieur Chow Lin.
Je mourrai là où je suis née.
Mais avant de m'en aller,
j'ai encore quelques
petites choses à régler.
Si j'avais un seul conseil
à donner,
je vous dirais, qu'il ne faut
jamais attendre qu'il soit trop tard.
Si on dansait ?
- Monsieur Wang ?
- Quoi donc ?
Vous êtes mandaté par l'Etat,
comment vous avez pu faire ça
avec ma mère ?
Victoria, on est Chinois !